who's the best actor you ever worked
with oh the one that just sticks in your
mind you're like this this is this is
the best actor I've ever worked with
besides me oh boy it's almost that I did
and I chickened out too Geraldine pagee
I I worked with her in white
nights yeah so I guess I it would be
Geraldine pige but uh she offered me
they she wanted me to when this one guy
was leaving to replace him and I thought
I I don't know if I could do it without
a rehearsal period so I made up a lie
that I I had another job and couldn't do
it you regret that uh yeah cuz I could
have worked with her you know in a in a
I mean but the when we did the movie we
were in the same scenes together but it
wouldn't have been like really playing
with her right